كفه ميزان متقاربه وحده المكون الكردي في
تركيا سيرجح احداهما على الاخرى استطلاعات
الراي حتى الان تشير الى تقارب محتمل في
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
فيما القادم بين تحالف المعارضه والتحالف
الحاكم بقياده اردوغان ليكون النخبون
الاكراد والمتمثلون بشكل اساسي في حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي ثالث اكبر احزاب تركيا
عامل الحسم في المعادله الانتخابيه
دور اكد عليه عدد من المحللين واشار اليه
صلاح الدين دمرداش السياسي الكردي المعتقل
الذي قاد حزب الشعوب الكردي
دمرتاج في احدث تصريحاته من السجن سلطه
الضوء على الفرصه الكبرى لانهاء حكم حزب
العداله والتنميه بقياده اردوغان والذي
امسك بيزيمار السلطه لما يقارب العقدين من
الزمن
[موسيقى]
خاصه ان عدد الناخل من الاكراد يصل الى 15
مليونا من اصل 65 مليون ناخب في البلاد ما
يشكل نسبه 18%
صفقه غير معلنه بين حزب الشعوب والمعارضه
التركيه قد ترجح كفه الاخيره وتزيد من
فرصه فوز مرشحها كما الكاليجدار اوغلو على
حساب منافسه اردوغان
يهددها عاملان اساسيان الاول هو حظر الحزب
من قبل الحكومه ومنعه من المشاركه في
الانتخابات اما الاخر فياتي من الطاوله
السداسيه ذات الطابع القومي التركي والتي
يرفض بعض اطرافها حزبا قوميا كرديا يتعارض
مع مبادئها وخوفا من خساره اصوات القوميين
الاتراك
دعم كبير كان يحصل عليه حزب العداله
والتنميه على مدار 20 عاما من قبل الاكراد
المحافظين معودين على قدره اردوغان لردم
الشروق العميقه بين الدوله والمكون الكردي
الا ان فشله وازدياد حده خطابه ضد الاكراد
وتهميشهم في الداخل وتدخلاته في المناطق
ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه في كل من العراق
وسوريا ايضا كانت العامل الذي قلب الطاوله
الكرديه على اردوغان ايفا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات